les problèmes d'environnement que nous
avons aujourd'hui sont des conséquences
de la mise en route de flux physique de
plus en plus importants qui ont été ceux
d'une activité économique de plus en
plus importante qu'est-ce que c'est que
l'activité économique quand on regarde
depuis la révolution industrielle s'est
produire en quantité croissante d'étapes
des chaises des voitures des maisons des
appareils des pistolets à eau et des
t-shirts et à chaque fois qu'on fait ça
on prend dans l'environnement des
ressources on les transforme et on
obtient à la fois le produit de la
transformation qui nous intéresse la
maison le t-shirt etc et des
sous-produits indésirables qui nous
intéressent pas du tout et qui s'appelle
la pollution et globalement plus on
transforme c'est-à-dire plus on a une
activité productive importante plus on
pollue plus on rejette de substances
dans l'air dans l'eau dans le sol etc
donc la croissance économique c'est la
croissance de la production et donc
c'est la croissance des rejets
globalement c'est tout à fait le cas si
on regarde en particulier le rejet
principal qui occupe mon activité
professionnelle de façon centrale
c'est-à-dire la question
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre
elles ont accompagné depuis un siècle et
demi
l'augmentation de la taille de
l'économie de façon parfaitement
corrélée alors on va y revenir justement
puisque on entend des Sandrine Rousseau
parler de la réforme des retraites
êtes-vous de ceux qui pensent que le
débat sur les retraites
occulte les vrais enjeux et en
particulier les enjeux liés aux
thématiques qui vous sont chères le
climat le réchauffement climatique alors
c'est amusant parce que coïncidence du
calendrier j'ai vu passer hier une
tribune de Jacques Attali dans Les Echos
alors je ne suis pas toujours d'accord
avec ce que raconte Jacques Attali mais
là en l'occurrence j'ai trouvé qu'il
posait une question qui était drôlement
bien sentie parlant de la réforme des
retraites il a titré sa tribune mais que
diable allait-il faire dans cette galère
donc en gros il posait la question en
disant pourquoi ça et pourquoi
maintenant et je me pose exactement les
deux mêmes questions pourquoi ce sujet
et pourquoi maintenant il me semble
incongru alors il y avait aucune urgence
à faire maintenant plutôt que l'année
prochaine ou dans deux ans
là je suis parfaitement en phase avec
les gens qui disent on a un tout petit
sujet avec la croissance c'est que la
les prévisions de croissance sont
absolument centrales dans les
projections qu'on peut faire sur
l'équilibre entre retraite et actif
or les projections de croissance du
Conseil d'orientation des retraites ne
se réaliseront pas elle ne se
réaliseront pas parce que ça fait déjà
maintenant plus de 10 ans que l'Europe
n'est plus en vrai croissance d'accord
on a une croissance qui est un peu
fictive qui est bon qu'est-ce qui vous
permet de dire que la croissance
effective alors j'y répondrai après je
laisse la question en
suspensable c'est une question qu'on
aborde assez souvent ici j'y reviendrai
après
en fait la production vraie de l'Europe
depuis plus de 10 ans elle est en
décroissance alors qu'est-ce que
j'appelle la production vraie par
exemple la quantité de mètres carrés
qu'on construit ça c'est physique par
exemple la quantité de tonnes qu'on
charge dans les camions ça c'est de la
production physique et bien quand vous
regardez la quantité de tonnes qu'on
charge dans les camions ça fait depuis
2007 en tendance à diminue donc ça veut
dire que en tendance l'Europe produit de
moins en moins de bien et transporte de
moins en moins de bien physique mes
fameux tapestes t-shirts etc tout ça en
tonnage donc en quantité physique ça
baisse depuis 15 ans et le fait que le
PIB facialement augmente il est lié à un
certain nombre de conventions qui sont
qui ont dit à cette augmentation
mécanique mais qui correspondent pas à
une augmentation des biens et des
services dont la population bénéficie
vraiment par exemple quand la valeur de
l'immobilier augmente les commissions
des agences immobilières augmentent ça
fait pas augmenter le nombre de mètres
carrés et ça c'est pas des flatter quand
vous faites le calcul du PIB la quantité
de crédit immobilier des banques
augmentent ça c'est pareil c'est pas
déflater donc la le produit net bancaire
augmente alors que vous avez pas plus de
mètres carrés qui font l'objet de
transaction augmentation voilà quand
vous avez la valeur des actions qui
augmente ou le ou la valeur des œuvres
d'art qui augmente vous avez un certain
nombre d'intermédiaires qui grâce à ça
gagne plus d'argent c'est pareil c'est
pas c'est pas corriger
et donc si je dis on regarde ce que les
gens ont vraiment à consommer en fait
vous vous rendez compte que depuis 15
ans il y a plus de croissance il y a
même une érosion légère et ça se traduit
même en termes strictement monétaire
pour les ménages puisque vous savez
probablement que le revenu disponible
déménagent en France diminue depuis 2010
la croissance elle est plutôt elle est
plutôt
faciale est une croissance spéculative à
l'avenir il y aura de la croissance
peut-être pas bon et mon pari c'est que
on sera plutôt malheureusement du coup
heureusement j'en sais rien du côté
peut-être pas bon or le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites dans les
trajectoires qu'ils trace pour l'avenir
ils se balade quelque part entre 0,7 %
et quasiment 2% de croissance du PIB par
an à l'avenir donc ça suppose qu'il y
aura pas de covid pas d'Ukraine et pas
de changement climatique et pas de
pénurie sur les matériaux et pas de
pénuries de pétrole et pas de etc tout
ça me paraît extrêmement discutable
alors pourquoi quel est le lien avec la
réforme actuelle le lien c'est qu'à
partir du moment où les hypothèses pour
l'avenir sont gentiment farfelus
on est certain oui on est certain qu'il
va falloir y revenir d'accord on est
certain qu'il va falloir y revenir
puisque la réforme qu'on est en train de
faire en ce moment se base sur des
hypothèses qui ne se réaliseront pas à
partir du moment où vous êtes certain
que vous allez devoir y revenir quelle
est l'urgence de faire ça maintenant
plutôt que l'année prochaine de ce que
ce sera peut-être plus dur après ce que
s'il va falloir y revenir 16h qui va
falloir faire une réforme encore plus
radicale après faut pas étaler les
réformes je ne sais pas du diable je ne
sais pas parce que d'ici là il y a plein
d'inflation qui sera passée il suffit
peut-être d'enterrer l'inflation vous
savez donc je sais pas je sais pas bon
donc il y avait pas d'urgence à faire
cette réforme à mon avis en début de
mandat alors que par contre il y a des
inconvénients absolument évident à
l'avoir fait c'est que Macron qui est
sur un deuxième mandat non rééligible
c'était l'occasion de mettre en oeuvre
des grandes ambitions très utiles au
pays et qui est des grands projets de
société quelque part pour lesquels on
aurait les bénéfices après le terme du
mandat bon là c'est clair que le sujet
des retraites tombe dans cette asymétrie
temporelle c'est à dire que il faut
souffrir maintenant pour avoir le
bénéfice plus tard quelque part
mais c'est pas un grand projet de
société c'est de l'intendance s'occuper
des retraites et donc il a raté
l'occasion en début de mandat de faire
quelque chose qui aurait eu du souffle
en rassemblant tout le monde et une fois
que il a commencé par crisper le pays en
divisant en deux sur quelque chose qui
est un problème d'intendance important
mais ça reste un problème d'intendance
il a il a quelque part il s'est mis en
position de faiblesse pour derrière
faire un grand projet egolien d'ambition
pour le pays voilà donc je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec avec Attali quand il
dit mais qu'est-ce qui lui a pris de
commencer par ça je pense effectivement
qu'est-ce qui lui a pris de commencer
par ça
puisque vous parliez de d'inflation tout
à l'heure
on devait se parler en janvier et à
l'époque il y avait des restaurateurs
qui ce qui était contraint de baisser
leur rideau des boulangers obligés de
mettre la clé sous la porte et des
entreprises forcées de stopper leur
production est-ce que tout ça c'était à
cause justement des explosion des est-ce
que on est entré enfin dans l'air de la
sobriété que vous appelez de vos vœux
alors non parce que la sobriété on est
entré dans l'air de la pauvreté mais pas
dans l'air de la sobriété je m'explique
dans maintenant que la nature à moi les
manières d'économiser de l'énergie je
les décompose en trois morceaux il y a
un morceau qui s'appelle l'efficacité
donc l'efficacité je vais prendre le
boulanger il vous fournit le même pain
et il l'a cuit à la même température
mais son four a demandé moins
d'électricité pour cuire le pain il est
plus efficace il est mieux isolé etc
d'accord ça c'est de l'efficacité
la deuxième la deuxième notion c'est la
sobriété donc la sobriété c'est vous
vous privez délibérément d'un produit ou
d'un service pour économiser
la production et les ressources
correspondantes alors je vais pas
prendre l'exemple du pain parce qu'on
peut pas imaginer que vous arrêtez de
manger du pain c'est pour un truc qui
est très très assimilé à des excès on va
dire de manger du pain il y a des bas
voilà mais
la personne la personne qui a la grosse
voiture de luxe qui est garée juste
devant l'entrée de l'immeuble là d'ici
il y a des bas pour savoir si c'est elle
est si grosse que ça et si elle est
Deluxe que ça elle est tout à fait
grosse et de luxe je ne donnerai pas la
marque mais je vous assure que c'est
gros c'est Deluxe
décide de ne plus utiliser sa voiture et
de prendre un abonnement Vélib
délibérément d'accord ça c'est de la
sobriété bon quand le gilet jaune ne
prend plus sa voiture parce qu'il a pas
les moyens de payer son plein ça c'est
pas de la sobriété c'est de la pauvreté
d'accord donc la sobriété et la pauvreté
c'est les mêmes gestes physiques je
change de type de mode de vie mais dans
la sobriété je l'ai choisi dans la dans
la pauvreté je donc là l'exemple que
vous me donnez sur le boulanger c'est
quelque chose qui est subi donc ça
rentre pas dans la catégorie de la
sobriété pour moi
est-ce que le facteur prix on le voit
notamment justement avec les questions
de facture d'électricité et ça s'arrête
pas ça continue on le voit est-ce que ça
va faire naturellement le travail de
réduction de consommation énergétique
alors oui mais d'une mauvaise manière
il y a trois façons il y a deux façons
plus exactement d'avoir une contrainte
qui vous impose une baisse de votre
consommation de quelque chose il y a la
contrainte par les prix le prix monte
vous pouvez plus le payer vous en
consommez moins et il y a la contrainte
réglementaire on vous demande par voie
de réglementaire de moins consommer de
quelque chose alors je vais prendre
l'exemple de l'énergie de chauffage
l'énergie de chauffage l'option A c'est
le gaz et le fuel ou alors prix
fortement monté donc vous en consommez
moins
option B on vous dit vous devrez vous
débarrasser de votre chaudière à gaz
pour remplacer ça par un poêle à bois ou
une pompe à chaleur et là vous allez
aussi consommer moins de gaz par la
force des choses
si vous prenez l'option réglementaire
vous avez la possibilité de planifier
quelque chose parce que la
réglementation vous pouvez dire c'est à
telle date c'est à tel vitesse c'est de
telle manière etc ça va bien avec une
planification si vous prenez l'option
prix c'est plus difficile de planifier
parce que si vous augmentez le prix du
gaz vous savez pas trop si le ménage en
face il va garder sa chaudière à gaz et
baisser le thermostat gardez sa
chaudière à gaz et couper le feu le
chauffage dans une pièce sur deux gardez
sa chaudière à gaz remplacer sa
chaudière à gaz par un poil par une
pompe à chaleur par déménager enfin vous
savez pas trop ce qu'il va faire quand
vous êtes dans la réglementation en
général vous savez mieux ce qu'il va
faire parce que vous lui imposez de
faire des choses et donc c'est mieux
pour planifier et notamment pour
planifier la production qui des
alternatives qui va en face
si vous attendez la hausse de prix c'est
quelque chose qui perd sur les deux
tableaux parce que vous avez
l'inconvénient de ne pas avoir planifié
l'alternative puisque la hausse de prix
elle dit pas immédiatement quelle est
l'alternative et en plus vous perdez
l'argent parce que à la différence d'une
hausse de prix qui arrive par la
fiscalité dans les Français ont horreur
comme chacun sait quand la hausse de
prix arrive par la hausse des prix de
marché
globalement c'est un appauvrissement du
pays ça veut dire que on doit acheter
plus cher les hydrocarbures au pays
exportateurs donc c'est un transfert net
d'argent de la France vers les autres
pays alors moi je veux bien que les
fonctionnaires français soient les
abrutis qui font n'importe quoi avec
notre argent mais je préfère quand même
donner mon argent à des fonctionnaires
français qui vont le recirculer dans le
pays plutôt qu'elles donnaient à des
fonctionnaires russes et saoudiens dont
je suis sûr qu'il ne vaut strictement
rien en faire pour mon pays alors un
certain nombre autre haute question
d'actualité il y a un certain nombre de
centrales qui ont été à l'arrêt pour
cause de maintenance en particulier 4
des plus puissants et des plus récents
réacteurs
ce sivot près de Poitiers c'est de
choses dans les dans les Ardennes alors
en cause c'était des fissures qui ont
été détectées sur les tuyaux est-ce que
selon vous le maintien de cet arrêt
était nécessaire ou est-ce que là on n'a
pas pêché par extrait de prudence on
aurait peut-être on aurait pu passer
outre et histoire de passer l'hiver il
revenir après et bien je vous avoue que
je ne suis pas un grand spécialiste
technique de la chose et j'ai entendu
les deux sons de cloche
dans son audition il faut prendre une
décision dans ces cas-là c'est en
l'occurrence moi je n'ai pas à prendre
de décision mais dans son audition à
l'Assemblée nationale dans le cadre
d'une commission d'enquête sur la perte
de souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétique de la France le président de
l'ASN a présenté
à présenter cette décision comme étant
parfaitement nécessaire et tout à fait
assumé par l'ASN nonobstant le fait que
ça privait la France d'une production
électrique importante et que ça a mis
les comptes des DF dans une situation
extrêmement dégradée
et j'ai par ailleurs des
j'ai entendu par des analyses de gens
qui connaissent bien la métallurgie des
de ce genre d'installation qui m'ont dit
on aurait pu attendre les opérations de
maintenance normale pour s'occuper du
problème c'était pas la peine de les
arrêter en urgence donc moi
personnellement je ne sais pas quoi
penser il faudrait que j'y passe de moi
à creuser le truc en détail je ce que je
sais
c'est que à l'avenir il n'est pas exclu
qu'on est de plus en plus souvent à
décider dans des situations dans
lesquelles aucune décision n'est
vraiment très confortable
pour ça je vous posais la question là là
on a eu un exemple il y en aura
probablement d'autres à l'avenir
vous préférez toujours vivre à Fukushima
plutôt que de vivre près d'une autoroute
alors si vous voulez en ce qui concerne
mes poumons sans hésiter une seconde oui
bien sûr vous savez que la pollution aux
particules fines tue des dizaines de
milliers de gens en Europe des dizaines
de milliers de gens chaque année
Fukushima n'a pas tué une personne à
cause du surplus de rayonnement relâché
dans l'environnement
merci jean-marco ici pour ses premiers
réponses il y a une semaine Louis
Gallois était l'invité de cette émission
nous lui avons demandé ce qu'il pensait
d'un mouvement d'étudiant je pose la
question parce que souvent des clients
on le trouve aussi bien Polytechnique
dont vous avez été un étudiant à l'agro
ou bien aux arts et métiers et avec des
ingénieurs qui sont favorables à la
décroissance quand on lui a posé la
question voici ce qui nous a répondu
du côté des écoles d'ingénieurs je leur
dis la décroissance c'est l'augmentation
des inégalités
parce que quand le gâteau est plus petit
c'est plus difficile de partager c'est
l'impossibilité de financer
l'amélioration des sciences publiques la
santé l'éducation de financer la
transition énergétique je pense que la
décroissance serait une catastrophe puis
en plus donner à un pays comme objectif
de diminuer ça me paraît absolument
aberrant sur le plan même j'allais dire
moral
alors est-ce que la décroissance serait
une catastrophe pour vous et est-ce que
la croissance comme le dit Louis Gallois
est nécessaire pour financer la
transition énergétique alors pour
financer la transition énergétique je ne
sais pas mais Louis Gallois a
parfaitement raison de souligner que la
croissance a permis l'augmentation de
d'un certain nombre de choses qui
aujourd'hui nous semble parfaitement
sympathique effectivement la
redistribution via l'impôt et quelque
chose qui a fortement augmenté à cause
de la croissance la croissance nous a
effectivement amené l'enseignement
l'hôpital et tout un tas d'autres choses
malheureusement là où je m'écarte de son
analyse c'est que je crois moi que ça
nous plaise ou que ça nous plaise pas
que la décroissance on va pas y couper
parce que ce qui a permis la croissance
et vous la souhaitez
c'est même pas le sujet pour moi je
est-ce que je souhaite vieillir non
absolument pas est-ce que je vieillis
oui c'est un fait donc c'est à dire que
la décroissance pour vous semble
inéluctable oui elle est inexorable pour
moi elle est aussi inexorable que le
fait que je vieillisse et aussi
sympathique ou peu sympathique selon la
façon que on va avoir de le gérer mais
je crois que de dire
il ne nous appartient qu'à nous de faire
en sorte que l'avenir soit de la
croissance ou de la décroissance je
pense que malheureusement c'est une
mauvaise manière de voir le problème je
pense que nous allons avoir de la
décroissance des flux physiques de façon
absolument inexorable et donc ça sera
physiquement plus dur de construire un
mètre carré physiquement plus dur de
déplacer une tonne à 100 km/h
physiquement plus dur de faire un mètre
carré de tissu rapidement ça sera
physiquement plus dur et la physiquement
pourquoi parce que
ça devenait de l'énergie qui va être
plus difficile avec de l'énergie et que
l'énergie qu'on le veuille ou qu'on le
veuille pas on va de toute façon en
avoir moins c'est à dire ou bien on le
voudra et on en aura moins pour des
raisons climatiques ou bien même si on
le veut pas on en aura moins quand même
pour des raisons géologiques il y a une
analyse du chiffre Project qui a été
publiée il y a maintenant un an vous
dirigez une association que je préside
qui qui est un thinkan donc ça produit
des analyses des rapports des
propositions etc et il y a un an on a
publié une analyse très exhaustive des
possibilités d'approvisionnement en
pétrole de l'Europe jusqu'en 2050 alors
en fait le travail qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on a regardé la quantité de pétrole
qui sortirait du sol du sous-sol plus
exactement des 16 premiers fournisseurs
de l'Europe d'ici à 2050 et la réponse
c'est que la production des 16 premiers
fournisseurs de l'Europe qui sont aussi
les 16 premiers producteurs mondiaux
sauf le Brésil et le Canada serait
divisé par deux d'ici à 2050 ce qui veut
dire que leurs exportations vers
l'Europe puisqu'ils vont d'abord servir
leur population domesticains ce va être
divisé par n'importe quoi entre 2 et 20
donc de toute façon même si on veut pas
des hydrocarbures on va en avoir
considérablement moins et il va bien
falloir qu'on s'organise en conséquence
ça refait le lien avec ce que je disais
tout à l'heure sur notre cher président
et ses retraites il me semble que
d'organiser le pays en fonction de ce
que je viens de dire et dans un deuxième
temps de savoir comment est-ce qu'on
organise les retraites dans ce truc
d'ensemble c'était mettre le problème
dans le bon ordre
les problèmes dans le bonheur donc là ce
que je dis simplement c'est que la
décroissance physique la diminution des
flux physiques qui structure l'économie
on ne va pas y couper et donc la bonne
question c'est comment est-ce qu'on
s'organise en conséquence et le
mouvement des jeunes ingénieurs
aujourd'hui dans les dans les écoles je
ne sais pas tant s'il est de souhaiter
la misère du monde ou de souhaiter qu'on
prenne acte des réalités du monde et que
enfin on fasse des efforts pour faire en
sorte de gérer le monde tel qu'il va
être et non pas tel qu'on aimerait qu'il
soit est-ce que la démondialisation
pourrait justement conduire à une
sobriété dans un certain nombre de
domaines notamment dans celui de
l'alimentation qui vous est cher
aujourd'hui on a du bœuf argentin du
mouton Zélande néo-zélandais on voyage
là pour le coup il faudrait l'organiser
alors d'abord la démondialisation elle
est déjà un tout petit peu en route
depuis 2008 la part du commerce
international dans le PIB a déjà perdu
alors je vais vous dire un truc de
mémoire elle a déjà dû perdre 10%. c'est
à dire que en 1970 sauf erreur de ma
part les échanges internationaux
représentaient 25% du PIB mondial c'est
monté jusqu'à 60% du PIB mondial en 2008
qui a été le maximum historique et
depuis il me semble que c'est redescendu
à 50
il se trouve que les échos ont publié un
graphique là-dessus pas plus tard
qu'hier bon je suis désolé de citer un
concurrent
et donc le donc la démondialisation elle
est déjà à petite vitesse un peu en
route en ce qui concerne l'agriculture
il se passe que vous savez des exemples
que vous avez cité il se trouve que la
France est quand même plutôt du bon côté
de la barrière au sens où on a un grand
territoire on a beaucoup de surfaces
cultivables et aujourd'hui si on importe
tous les produits que vous avez cité on
importe de plus en plus de poulet à
étrangers on apporte de plus en plus de
buffs étrangers on apporte etc alors bon
c'est pas pousser beaucoup d'enches chez
nous mais il y a quand même beaucoup de
choses que on peut faire pousser chez
nous c'est plutôt dû à des structures de
marché plutôt qu'à l'impossibilité
physique de faire tout ce qu'on pourrait
faire chez nous donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui s'organise mais ça c'est un
sujet de de comment dire de cadre global
il se trouve que l'Europe s'est dotée
d'un cadre global sur l'agriculture qui
à mon avis n'est pas adapté au défi que
nous allons avoir pour l'avenir et c'est
un problème qui doit se traiter au
niveau Européen puisque c'est à l'Europe
que nous avons confié la compétence en
la matière il nous reste peu de temps
Jean-Jacques
le plus un climato-sceptique ou un
nucléaire
un indifférent à la question
m'ennuie encore plus c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui je suis beaucoup plus
inquiet de l'existence d'une classe
politique et de d'une classe dirigeante
économique qui n'a pas l'air de réaliser
dans quel monde on va vivre que d'un
anti-nucléaire ou d'un climato-sceptique
est-ce que vous demandez toujours au
gouvernement de vous accorder trois
heures pour une explication
20h oui
est-ce que vous êtes capable de faire un
prix à une heure comme vous l'avez fait
est-ce que vous devenez expert-comptable
en 30 minutes non donc à partir du
moment où il y a qu'un sujet vraiment
important sur qui est vraiment
structurant j'insiste pour l'avenir du
pays il me semble que ça vaut bien trois
heures que répondez-vous à ceux qui
pensent que le renouvelable est plus sûr
que le nucléaire
vous avez des alors ça dépend ce qu'on
appelle sur quel plan ça dépend sur quel
plan sur le plan sanitaire c'est inexact
vous avez des analyses enfin des travaux
de médecins qui ont été faits qui
donnent le nombre de morts par gigawater
ou mégawattheure ou terawattheure des
diverses sources de production
électrique les journalistes au berger
est venu sur plateau et elle nous a dit
que les éoliennes sont le prochain
scandale sanitaire alors je ne sais pas
si c'est le prochain scandale sanitaire
mais en tout cas ce que je sais c'est
que si vous mettez dans les
renouvelables les barrages ils ont
beaucoup plus tué avec les centrales
nucléaires beaucoup et même sans mettre
les barrages les autres vous avez des
accidents de mines vous avez parce que
il faut les métaux pour faire les
éoliennes et les panneaux solaires et en
fait si vous comptez ce genre de truc
vous vous rendez compte que c'est
kif-kif avec le nucléaire la raison pour
laquelle on a fermé Fessenheim c'est
pour montrer à EDF qui est le chef c'est
ce que c'est dites-vous à nos confrères
de Marianne ce que vous a confié le
délégué interministériel à la fermeture
de Fessenheim Francis roll Tanguy vous
confirmez qu'il vous a bien dit ça oui
c'était pour montrer à Ed qui était le
chef et pas pour les questions
environnementales alors c'était
peut-être aussi pour des questions
environnementales invoquées je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas je vous confirme
que j'ai bien entendu ça dans le bureau
de Monsieur rotang Jean-Marc Jancovici
le monde sans fin avec Christophe
Christophe blanc c'est aux éditions
Dargo il n'y a aucun des ratum de
l'éditeur je tiens à le préciser c'est
absolument passionnant ça vaut son prix
et c'est c'est vraiment captivant on ne
le quitte pas ça pose des problèmes
sociaux dans son entourage parce que
vous passez votre week-end avec la avec
la BD mais ça vaut le coup c'est donc
aux éditions d'Argo merci beaucoup
Jean-Marc Jancovici
[Musique]